are you mindful your predecessor
couldn't out survive a lettuce Ked armor
doesn't have a plan do you think he's a
terrorist sympathizer the fact speak for
themselves can you say you have grown
the economy NHS waiting list you failed
on that Pledge yes can I tell you a
personal story this my mother is 79 she
had a heart attack and she was put on a
trolley in a corridor for nearly 7 hours
I think that's
shocking I've never understood this
Randa thing it seems to me a completely
cack-handed policy why is this the hill
you want to die on but you don't have an
alternative way to solve that problem
I'm not prime
minister pm and the PM round two prime
minister how how are you I'm good thanks
how are you well it was a year ago we
sat In This Very Room in these very
chairs uh you just had them all done up
actually was very nice um and you said
to me then right I've just done these
five main pledges come back in a year
and judge me on how I've done I did and
I'm going to do that but before we get
to the the five pledges and thank you
for keeping the sixth pledge which I
appreciate um how are you finding it
being promin you just become Prime
Minister last time and it was once
described to me by someone who' been
prime minister that it's when you first
get the job it's like being in a choppy
ocean and you're getting hit by wave
after wave after wave and you think my
God I'm I'm drowning and then you start
to realize it's always like that and you
start to ride the wavs and enjoy it more
are you finding that well I think when
we were here a year ago you described it
as the worst Hospital pass for any
incoming prime minister ever and I knew
it wasn't going to be easy and look
candidly country's been through a lot in
the last couple of years we had covid
and all the impact that had Legacy of
backlog and public services then we had
a war in Ukraine with all the impact
that had on energy bills so there's a
lot that happened but I genuinely
believe beginning of this year country
is pointing in the right direction we've
made progress the plans that we put in
place which we'll get into are working
and if we stick with it there a brighter
future ahead for everyone but that's
what we're going to get into today so I
look I I feel good I feel we're making
progress and that's the main thing the
last time I saw you was a a hilarious by
chance moment uh midair on a plane
flying to Los Angeles for what was your
only family holiday I believe in the
last four and a half years yeah and
apart from the fact I wrecked the start
of it obviously um but also it just
really brought it home to me how all
consuming these jobs can be when there's
a lot going on when you've got a
pandemic to deal with and all this thing
to have just one week with your family
as genuine holiday did you ever
anticipate that you'd have to have a
life like this well you know I didn't I
didn't take on this job thinking I'd
have lots of holiday I knew it was going
to be tough and that's right because
there's a lot to get on with and I also
didn't think when I had my first holiday
in four and a half years that you'd be
sitting there next to me for 10 or 11
hours so I mean how how bad a moment was
that when you dusted yourself down lay
back looked to your right and saw me
sitting there it was
fine it was fine I think we had a good
chat about Cricket I think all way
through the fight no it's fine no
actually I was excited to be a to
actually because you say family is
important to me I don't spend enough
time with my kids as a result of the job
which is as one would expect um so it
was really nice to have a little bit of
time to spend with that reminds you how
important it is how do the family find
it I mean it is a massive change in
lifestyle to suddenly be living here at
number 10 with everything that goes with
it the pressure on their husband their
dad yeah they're I have two little girls
they I think they know it's a privilege
right and they recognize it's a great
privilege to live in this building with
all the history my younger daughter in
particular loves history she can give a
great tour of the building with all the
things that happened in all the rooms so
they they're lucky enough to appreciate
it they're all also young enough that
what I do doesn't massively impact them
or bother them is it cool to have you as
a dad at school or is it not very cool I
think probably not very
cool I had um that period before I was
doing this this job I had a kind of five
weeks when I was between jobs as someone
put it um at the end of the summer and
the Autumn and then I was very involved
in their lives doing school run every
morning pickups organizing snacks doing
the homework I'm not sure that they
loved all of that to be perfectly honest
so the right balance yeah exactly
they're probably a bit happier with this
balance what do you do with the Cricket
on England India I was thinking of you
this morning we're massive Cricket fans
I I was curious I mean who do you
support I support England and what about
the rest of the family well you know I
I've tried very hard to get my girls
into cricket and have not massively
succeeded thus far I've said to them
though because obviously that you their
mom's Indian so I said football they
definitely support England I said
Cricket it's up to them who they want to
support but your wife backs India yeah
she but again I I can't say that she
loves loves crickets specially she was
very irritated with me the other Sunday
morning when I woke everyone up early it
was an amazing game amazing game Tony
Blair has announced he's releasing a
book about leadership and he says of
being prime minister in the in the sort
of blurb for this book governing a
country is in one sense a little like
being the national football coach of a
football crazy nation everyone has an
opinion everyone thinks they can do it
and do it better than you do you
recognize that yeah yes funny enough I I
was very lucky to meet Gareth Southgate
and the England football team a little
while ago at St George's park because we
announced that we'd won the Euros that
we're going to host here which is going
to be exciting and he and I were joking
about that who has the toughest job but
look you know well what did you do
conclude who well I think I think well I
wouldn't say I he has tough job too but
he's doing he's doing a great job
actually incredible job and this is a
tough job it's tough because of the
context effect that we were talking
about and obvious everyone's going to
have an opinion but that's fine that's
okay like that's how it should be my job
is to crack on make a difference to
people focus on the things that matter
to them and then ultimately you know
they'll judge at the end of the day has
it made you a bit
harder I think well you obviously have
to have tough you know tough skin to do
this um but I'm fine with that you've
got a tough skin yeah and you have to
have it in this job right because to
your point everyone us has an opinion
everyone's got a view and some of it's
quite personal but you know my view is
look if you're working as hard as you
can if you're doing what you believe to
be right you're doing it with the right
intentions focusing on the things that
matter and you know then you sleep well
at night right I did a brief focused
group this morning as I was on my way
here um and in fact when I got here I
asked my Builder Terry I'm interviewing
the Prime Minister what do you want he
said cut my bleep
taxes uh I asked one of my best village
mates he said tell him to get a
grip and then I asked your policeman on
the way in he said do something
something about police
wages so there you are there's a strong
po there's a St po which didn't surprise
me because uh everybody if you ask them
right what do you want from the Prime
Minister they'll all have a bit of
self-interest about it and we're living
in a time when it's difficult right it's
not easy street out there for almost
anybody yeah I I think I think most
fair-minded people recognize that it is
difficult it was difficult when I got
the job but I also think that we're
making progress right and we'll get into
all the detail of it but you know you
talk that first one you said you know
cut your taxes well you know we are now
starting to be able to cut people's
taxes everyone in their pay sliping the
last week in January has got the start
of a tax cut that's worth 50 Chancellor
seems to be changing the mood music
about just how much you might be cutting
taxes having LED everyone into the
promised land of actually it's going to
be quite big tax cuts now he's sort of
saying well we may not better do that
well we've got to do these things
responsibly and that's why look when I
first got this job I said look the first
priority is is bringing inflation down
because it's inflation that's causing
pressures with the cost of living and I
always said that the long-term plan is
if we are disciplined we get inflation
down and it's come down from 11% to 4%
more than half I said because economic
situation is now better we're in a
position to cut taxes that's what we've
delivered as I said someone on an
average salary it fair to say that right
now you will not be able to in the in
the short term the next budget cut the
taxes as much as you would have liked to
now I never get into this budget
speculation but the direction of travel
is clear but we've always said we have
to do that responsibly right and it has
to be part of a plan and we've started
that said the first tax cuts come in
it's meaningful as I said someone
earning an average salary about 35k 450
quid in the pay slip starting in January
so that's progress but if we stick to
the plan then yes we'd like to cut more
taxes but the answer is why because it's
not just about money in people's pockets
good as that is it's about the type of
country that I want to build and it's
one where hard work is rewarded I
believe very strongly in that I believe
when people work hard that should be
rewarded and a way to do that is to make
sure they can keep more of their own
money and that's the type of society
that I want to build and actually
cutting taxes is an expression of that
but it has to be part of a plan and I'm
pleased that the plan we've put in place
on that is working are you mindful
constantly that your predecessor lasted
less than 50 days in fact in the end
couldn't out survive a lettuce because
she decided to just dramatically cut
taxes and tank the economy in the past
are you constantly reminding yourself
you've got to tread carefully here yeah
I mean that's we had a debate over it
that that summer about our approaches
and I can't change the past but that's
really actually you talk about that
moment that's why I did this job because
it was that moment in time country was
in a tough spot and I felt that I could
make a difference I've got an economic
background I think people trust that I
know what I'm doing when it comes to the
economy and at that moment I thought
country's I said in a difficult spot and
I love this country more than anything
it's done an enormous amount for my
family and I can make a difference and
that's why I knew it was going to be
tough but that's why I put myself
forward to do this because I thought
first and foremost I can make sure that
we get our economy in a better place and
I'm really pleased that on that we have
really we've made progress we'll come to
the the pledges in particular in a bit
Tony Blair also said in the blur for his
book the role of leader as prime
minister is a privilege of course but a
privilege that is painful the most
painful part he said is to get things
done you arrive arrive in power as the
great Persuader you govern as the CEO
persuasion is about talking governing is
about
doing yeah I recognize that and actually
there's a lot of just hard graft to this
job now if you want to affect change a
lot of it is a lot of meetings
downstairs in the cabinet room just
going over things being across the
detail pushing pushing pushing and
there's no substitute for graft but
that suits me right I'm prepared to do
that and I believe that's what you
should do in this job and and when we'll
get on to talking about some of the
things we've we've done illegal
migration being an obvious one where
we've got the numbers down for the first
time we're going to come to that because
I have strong views about that yeah good
and bad for you on that actually and
look I I think my take about this whole
situation I've interviewed a lot of
prime ministers just have in the last 25
years and when times are good when it's
easy it's the best job in the world but
they've all then had times when it goes
bad or it's tough or whatever and it
becomes incredibly difficult and I don't
for a moment think that you don't have a
very difficult job I don't think anybody
thinks that you don't it's just whether
you can persuade people this year as the
clock ticks down to whatever you call
that election whether you can persuade
people in that time that you're the guy
to lead us out of this or not yeah I but
I think you're absolutely right right I
think people recognize the context as
tough and my pitch is look I know what
people want they want peace of mind that
future is going to be better for them
and their families they want a renewed
sense of pride in our country that's
what I want to deliver but we can only
deliver that if you've got a plan and
that plan is working and I believe we do
and I believe now we're starting to see
that the plan is working we're making
progress and my job is to show to people
look if we stick with this we can have
that better future we can have that
renewed sense of pride in our country
and I'm going to spend every day every
week every month demonstrating that and
when we get to that election ultimately
it's a choice it's not just about me and
what I'm doing it's about me or k armor
in the labor party and I'd say there
look the guy's been leader of the
opposition for four years he can't tell
you what he do differently because he
doesn't have a plan and you don't bring
about any positive change in our country
who a Charisma battle between you two
look I'm not interested in that what I'm
interested in is who can bring about you
think you're you think you're more
charismatic other people were judge but
what I does it matter to be the battle
that I want to win is this right the
battle I want to win is that people can
see that actually who's more likely to
bring about that positive change that I
want to see and I want them to realize
that actually it's me with a plan that
is working and they can see that in
spite of how difficult things have been
the fact that the plan we put in place
is starting to show progress will give
them the confidence that I can deliver
the change they want that's the battle
that I want okay and we will come to the
pledges don't worry we'll go through
them in detail one thing that really
struck me this week which I wanted to
talk to you about uh before we get into
that is the safety of our
politicians is very concerning we've had
two British politicians murdered in the
last eight years or so and we've just
had your Justice Minister Mike FR saying
he's going to quit Parliament at the
next election after a series of death
threats from islamist extremist and an
Arsen attack on his constituency office
and he said that he escaped being killed
by David amos's Killer by the skin of
his teeth because he happened to not be
in his constituency when that killer was
looking at his office
but you have obviously I presume a lot
of threats you have a lot of security
that deals with it that goes with the
job as it does in many of the offices of
state but the average MP doesn't have
that and it just struck me is it not
time and is it in your gift to do this
to actually give every single member of
parliament on both s all parties a a
bodyguard a security guard I think the
public would support that I don't want
to see more elected officials
murdered no of course no one wants to
see that and actually I was speaking to
Mike just yesterday and it's awful what
he's had to enure his office essentially
being attacked and set on fire the
threats he's received and everyone
regardless of the political party that
they're a member of gets into this
because they believe in public service
and they want to make a difference and
they should be able to do that without
fearing for their personal safety now
actually Houses of Parliament have put
in place over the years more things to
protect MPS Security in their offices at
their homes and it's something that's
constantly being reviewed but I think as
well as looking at that which you're
right of course we should do which are
the practical things we've also got to
look at the ideology that is driving
that kind of behavior and that's making
sure that we tackle it at its roote
right what we can't have is that kind of
extremist ideology festering in
communities on our streets at leads
people to behave in that particular way
and I think that's equally important do
you think the idea of each of them
having a security guard is a good idea
no well generally these are better
answers that well questions that are
better put to the police and our
security services I mean look there
there may well be an argument for that
seems to me they're very vulnerable in
their constituency offices every MP and
and more protection has been put in
place at most MP's constituency offices
where they have access to alarm systems
system to assume you're looking at this
I in general as I was actually as
talking to Mike and talking to others we
always want to make sure that MPS are
safe and as you said it's incredibly sad
what we've seen But as well as the
Practical security of MPS which is
Paramount it's the culture that leads to
that type of extremist behavior that
doesn't just impact MPS it impacts other
people as well and we've got to be
equally tough on calling out that kind
of behavior as well do you get told
about threats to you uh I mean yes is it
unnerving yeah I mean it look I'm very
fortunate in the sense I have an
incredible team of people whose you job
it is to to keep me safe and it comes
with the territory um I people remember
you know you know people came and
protested at my house which was
obviously slightly unset actually I
think that happened literally while yeah
I was uh on my way uh to over to the
states with you on the plane that was
happening and that that is unnerving
because you know when your home is
invaded in that way it feel you feel
very vulnerable but it's not just about
me it actually goes to a broader thing I
want my two girls to be a to grow up in
a society that's safe which is why you
know I'm quite focused on putting more
police officers on the
crucially giving them the tough Powers
they need to say confiscate knives off
people um which is really important make
sure we have things like CCTV and Street
lighting so you know girls like mine
when they grow up and women can feel
safe when they walk home at night like
that's the type again that's the type of
society that I want type of country that
we should have people feel concerned
when they see these Pro Palestinian
marches many of whom are Marching
completely peacefully and for all the
right reasons uh and should be respected
but there are plenty of people brazenly
flouting the laws supporting Hamas
chanting Jihad chanting from The River
To The Sea and I think people feel that
more should be done to stop that that
that if if more is not done then it it
fuels that kind of extremism and
emboldens yeah which is completely wrong
and some of the scenes that we've seen
are unacceptable I mean the rise of
anti-Semitism in particular over the
last few months is appalling I mean in
our country in this age Jewish people
feel genuinely me friends your friends
when their kids are not wearing their
school uniform right when they're hiding
their star of Davids I mean this is what
do you feel yeah I feel shocked to my
core that in our country in this age
that has happened happened that people
feel they have to hide their identity
it's obviously appalling so what are we
doing well we're giving more funding to
the organization that protects Jewish
places of faith for example and others
and we're talking to the police about
whether extra powers are needed to
properly police these protest so that is
a conversation where I've been very
clear if we think that there are new
powers that they need in order to
effectively deal with some of the things
that we're all seeing then we are very
open to doing that and legislating and
bringing forward quite tough things um
but right now if there is someone that's
breaking the law I've been very clear
with all the police those people should
face the full force of the law there
should be absolutely you know no
tolerance for this and when people are
doing things that we can all see with
our own eyes or people sharing videos
the police should be going after those
people and getting them locked up and
that's what I've told them but if they
need more powers to do that then that's
what we will do I interviewed an NHS
doctor of more than 20 years wahed
Shader who also had a name Abdul wahed
he was the leader of the islamist group
hisb but terer Britain uh and he'd been
a NHS doctor the entire time that he was
also running this group you've just as a
government prescribed them as a terror
group he is still registered with the
General Medical counsil I mean what
should happen so I think my
understanding is actually that the NHS
are looking into all yeah so I think
they're looking into that and obviously
professional bodies independent from the
government we've been very clear about
hisb terer they should be a prescribed
terrorist organization we're bringing
forward the legislation to do that and
again you know question for K starma he
Once Upon a Time represented his but
toer actually he he supported them in
resisting prescription elsewhere and
that is like that's who he was on the
side of we're busy trying to ban these
people and he was busy trying to you
think he's a terrorist sympathizer well
I said the facts speak for themselves
right like he there he was he was their
lawyer when they were trying to resist
this we've just prescribed them because
we think that's what they are and I just
speak again these things speak to
people's values right as a general
principle you shouldn't be able to
continue as an NHS doctor if you are
leading this group in this country yeah
well from this moment on remember these
things are forward-looking but it's
there's clearly questions to answer
which the NHS are rightly looking at
because he came on my show and he was so
Brazen I mean really brazen celebrated
October the 7th he felt it was
resistance foret punch in the face
forget without it's not obviously right
for me to comment on individual people
but let me just be clear forget about
working in a particular place it is
illegal for a prescri for a prescribed
terrorist organization for someone to be
glorifying that organization and what
they do is already illegal under our law
and that's the same in these protests
when you see people glorifying what
Hamas have done that is against the law
right that is not in accordance with the
values of our country and those people
should be accountable for that I I felt
like I know you did that October the 7th
was one of the most horrendous Terror
attacks of modern times and that Israel
not only has a duty to defend itself but
as a moral compulsion to protect its
people right I think we would feel the
same way here the big question is
whether what they've been doing since is
proportionate in your estimation is it
proportionate given the massive civilian
death toll and in particular the number
of children and women being killed yeah
so actually where where you first
started as the place that I start you
know imagine if that had happened here
over a thousand people women children
slaughtered raped all of this absolutely
appalling Act of terrorism and I think
Israel as any country would has not just
the right but the duty to defend itself
and its people and make sure that that
doesn't ever happen again and that means
going after Hamas and I think as I said
it's not just a right I think that's a
duty that anyone would expect of their
own government if something like that
happened to them but is also incumbent
on Israel to take every care to avoid
harming civilians and I've made that
point repeatedly to prime minister
Netanyahu and you know I'm concerned
about the loss of civilian life in Gaza
too many civilians have lost their lives
and there are people who are in
Desperate Straits from a humanitarian
perspective which is why we've been
trying very hard to get more Aid into
God
again I've kept pushing the prime
minister to open up more Aid routes the
UK do there be a ceas now we've been
very clear we think there should be an
immediate pause to get hostages out
because remember Hamas still are holding
many hostages so I think there should be
an immediate pause to get hostages out
to get more Aid in and build the
conditions for a sustainable ceasefire
but for it to be sustainable and truly
sustainable you know we have to address
the situation of Hamas we can't have a
terrorist organization still in charge
we can't have them a able to fire
Rockets into Israel so as part of a
sustainable ceasefire those things need
to be addressed but look in the
immediacy do I want a pause to get
hostages out and Aid in yes we do and
that's what we've been calling for I
mean 10,000 children in Gaza have been
killed 19,000 more have been orphaned
65% or so of Gaza has been flanked I
mean is what is going on is
devastating have you considered I mean
you in a moral quandry as I've been
about the scale of this response and
where that limit should be before
countries like ours say enough yeah look
of course we think through all these
things and I've I said been very clear
very direct with prime minister
Netanyahu whilst I support and we
support Israel's right to defend itself
and remove the threat that Hamas poses
to its people because we have to start
there in all cases imagine if that had
happened in our country what people
would rightly expect of the government
they have to do that in a way that
avoids best as possible harming
civilians and too many have lost their
lives and not enough Aid is getting in
is it helpful that prime minister
Netanyahu continues in his job it's NE
look it's never appropriate for for me
to comment on other countries domestic
politics right but what we will do
continually is call on Israel to allow
more Aid into Gaza to help all the
people as you said children who are not
getting the medicine the food that they
need and we're playing a leading role in
that people should be proud we've
tripled the amount of aid into the
region recently when I spoke to prime
minister Netanyahu I said why can't we
open up another Aid Route so we're not
reliant on going through Egypt does he
want to hear anyone who doesn't just go
along with what he wants to do yeah I
mean he seems very blinkered in what
he's now doing actually we've managed
over time to increase the number of
trucks which are going into Gaza still
not enough but compared to where we were
at the beginning we have persuaded him
to open up the crossing to get hundreds
of trucks in but we need hundreds more
so that there is progress that has been
made but it's nowhere near enough and I
will keep pushing so that we can get the
support that we need to people in Gaza
and at the same time work as you were
talking about work for that sustainable
ceasefire something that releases the
hostages gets more Aid in and actually
then Works towards a better future for
the people of Gaza where they can live
with dignity with security with
opportunity side by side people in
Israel that's the future that we all
want for reg and your foreign secretary
Lord Cameron uh has sign what appears to
be quite a shift in UK policy this week
when he said that the political
perspective of a credible route to
Palestinian State a new future must be
given to the Palestinians it needs to be
irreversible it's not entirely in our
gift but Britain and our partners can
help by confirming our commitment to a
sovereign viable Palestinian State and
our vision for its composition and
crucially must State our clear intention
to granted recognition including at the
United Nations that does seem to be a
move in our policy as a country no it's
look our position is the same and we
David was saying like we are committed
to a two-state solution right we
absolutely are committed that's been the
long-standing position of the UK
government and actually what's happened
over the last few months has reminded us
that we need to redouble our efforts to
bring that about working with all our
partners in the region I went very soon
after the attacks to meet with everyone
in the region to talk about this and
we're playing a role I met with the
president of the Palestinian Authority
specifically to talk about about this
but we have to think about that in the
context of what's going on right now and
that's why the immediate Primacy is to
get Aid in get hostages out build the
conditions for a sustainable would you
countenance if you were prime minister
actually saying that we now consider
there's a Palestinian State before a
conclusion to a peace and that's where I
think that there has been no that's the
way people have perceived his comments
to be and that's not the the
government's longstanding position is
has been that we will recognize a
Palestinian State at the time that it's
most conducive to the peace process so
only once the process is finished yeah I
think it's hard to you would preempt
it's hard to conclusion of that but it's
a it's it's a difference yeah and I
think it's been over I said I think it's
been over interpreted like what we are
absolutely committed to as a two-state
solution the recognition of Palestine
should come at a point where that is
most conducive to the overall process
but at the moment you're not looking to
preempt anything no at the moment what
we're looking to do is build the
conditions to get hostages out Aid in a
sustainable ceasefire that looks forward
to the future that the foreign secretary
talked about where Israelis and
Palestinians can live side by side both
with dignity with peace with security
and opportunity that's the future and
that's what we need to work with all our
partners to bring about which we are
doing um and part of the work we're
doing is to show that that is viable and
possible to help get the conditions
right now for a pause in in fighting
when you look at the resolution of the
troubles in nor Island and it's very
encouraging that we're looking to see
the power sharing executive is now going
to be back up and running and
congratulations on that it's a
significant achievement but do you see
parallels between Northern Ireland and
Israel Palestine for many decades it
looked like there could be no resolution
in noran and then there was do you think
we can achieve the same yeah midd e i
I'm I'm obviously newer to this but
Northern Ireland is closer to home and
important to me is the UK prime minister
and I am pleased that we have been able
to resolve the situation in Northern
Ireland because fundamentally there's
millions of people who have been without
a government for too long and they
haven't been able to have their elected
politicians focus on their priorities
for you know we all know why that
happened but through the Windsor
framework which I concluded probably
shortly after you and I were sitting
here a year ago and now the the New Deal
that we've reached there is now the very
real Prospect of the executive being
back up and running in Northern Ireland
people having the devolved government
that they deserve and need to address
all the things that are going on and
that is really positive and and I've
learned through that process more about
the necessity of sitting down and
talking to people working through
problems and we talked about you talked
about before about the you know the work
that it requires there is a lot of graft
in that there's a lot of detail that you
need to work through but shows that when
we can take on big problems we can fix
them and that's my take away from
experience in Northern Ireland and
actually I'm confident that that can be
done elsewhere as well because with the
best you know got will in the world and
everyone working towards the same thing
I tend to be an optimist you've been
very strong in supporting Ukraine which
I've been pleased to see I think it's
the right thing for our country to be
doing do you fear that the support In
America which is going to be critical
may be drifting the wrong way so when I
was in the states last year I spent a
lot of time on the hill talking to
people from both parties in Congress and
I I didn't detect that I think there is
actually broad bipartisan support in the
US for more support to Ukraine I think
what people unsurprisingly want to see
given that the US is by far and away the
single biggest provider of that support
is they want to see other allies
stepping up now if I was a US taxpayer
if I was a US politician I'd probably
say the same thing Hang on we're going
to do this what about everyone else and
that's why it was important to me that
the UK demonstrated leadership I was the
first foreign leader there this year was
my first visit we were the first people
to announce significant support for this
year first country to sign a multi
Ukraine is great but that that will help
actually make the argument in America
that they can count on us as an ally so
they're not shouldering the entire
burden themselves and I think that was
why I wanted to go early because I think
that will I said make it easier to win
the argument in the US if Russia was to
turn its turrets in our direction is
this country
prepared properly to defend itself
yes and one of my first job is to keep
everybody safe and unfortunately you
know the world is becoming less safe and
we can see that obviously with the
situation in Russia and Ukraine but most
recently we've been seeing it in the Red
Sea where for the first time in decades
people are trying to fire missiles at
one of our Royal Navy vessels they're
disrupting shipping uh and that is
actually we can't pretend these things
don't affect us cuz every ship that has
to get re-rooted ultimately adds more
cost to the things that people are
buying every day and we've just live
through the impact of that because of
our energy bills so I actually oddly by
coincidence was in Ukraine at the same
time as that we were participating with
the US on self-defense strikes against
the hooti group and that kind of
demonstrates the world we're living in
but that's why we've increased our
investment in defense spending um and
it's something that I spend forces and
I've got my brother was is a retired
army colonel my sister married a guy's
now retired was an Army colel lot of
concern about the the actual numbers we
have in our armed forces are you
concerned we don't have enough so my job
is to put the right investment in which
we've done I did that first of all as
Chancellor where we put the largest
increase of funding into the mod since
the end of the Cold War and we've
committed to maintain that and
increasing it over over time because
that reflects the environment we're
living in now how that is split between
all the different things that the Armed
Forces think they need whether it's new
technology equipment Personnel is more a
function of them and what they think is
the best way to protect ourselves and do
what we need to do as opposed to to me
but in general do I think we are well
protected well invested yes we are the
second biggest defense spender in NATO
we have been M to to Putin I mean as you
can see from what we've done in Ukraine
like we will stand up for the things
that we believe in we won't let
aggression go unchecked and unpunished
and actually what he can see is that we
have come together with our allies he
that we are not divided what he has
served to do is unite everybody increase
the amount that we're all spending in
defense we got new members of NATO so
actually strategically this has already
been a failure for him uh because he has
not achieved any of those objectives and
we're in a much stronger position now to
resist further aggression from him and
others around the world that would seek
to do likewise let's turn to the pledges
that was the
warmup you made five ples in your
January 2023 speech you said these are
the people's priorities they are your
government's priorities we will either
have achieved them or not no tricks no
ambiguity rather delivering for you or
we're not we will rebuild trust in
politics through action or not at all so
I ask you to judge us on the effort we
put in and the results we achieve I will
only promise what I can deliver and I
will deliver what I promise that's a big
statement you know I thought it was
ballsy if I'm honest with you for a
politician who's just become Prime
Minister to say that and then to specify
five
criteria how many of the five do you
think you've met well I think we've made
good progress on all of them and we
should go through how many of you met as
we see well we should go through because
we're going to I wonder in totality out
of the five I think we've made when
you're score scoreboarding yourself what
do you think I think we've made good
progress on the economic ones which are
the first three to Harve inflation grow
the economy and reduce debt we have not
made progress on cutting waiting lists
which will get into and we have made
progress on stopping the boats but there
is more to do and we'll get on to that
as well U but I should take a step back
before we get into it you said it was
ballsy and surprising but that was what
I wanted to do I wanted to do something
different in the sense that I wanted to
be a different type of politician and I
wanted to say look you can hold me
accountable for things I'm not going to
obis skate none of this was easy I knew
it wouldn't be easy but I wanted to be
clear what I was focused on because
they're not just my priorities I think
they're people's priorities country's
priorities and I wanted to be held
accountable for them as I said you come
back in a year here we are well the
reason I thought it was ballsy was I
knew that you would be judged now as
you're in an election here and if you
didn't deliver on those five pledges
then the the the electorate might take a
rather dim view of it given the
pronouncement you made back in January
23 and I think I think actually as we
were talking right at the beginning I
think people are completely fair-minded
they will judge us on the effort we're
putting in the results we're achieving
and they'll make their determination
about the future actually about who's
going to keep delivering change that
they want to see I think well let me put
my teacher hat on yeah let's go through
let's go through the report yeah Mr suak
um well the first one was to have
inflation by the end of 2023 you did it
now most people thought you probably
would and here here's my question for
you do you want to actually take credit
for Haring inflation because I don't
remember you taking any blame on the way
up as it soar to 11% is it really not
the case that it's mostly out of your
control inflation so yes it's great that
you've met your pledge but how much of
that is down to you look well all of
these things there's always a mix of
factors but that was the most important
thing for me to focus on when I got this
job the cost of living dominated
everything it's the biggest impact on
families up and down the country and I
said we needed to Harve inflation
because that's best thing we could do to
help everyone and I'm pleased that we've
more than delivered it as you said from
11% down to
and I'd say there was a big period in
the Middle where it wasn't obvious that
we were going to hit it and I could find
LS of you journalists commentating and
saying that that's not going to happen
so I don't but how much do you think was
down to you I do because I don't think
these things happen by accident I don't
think these things happened by accident
it was not a foregone conclusion it
requires governments to take difficult
decisions and there'll be other things
that people have wanted me to do spend
money on this borrow that where I've
said no that's not the right thing to do
because we've got to get want credit for
getting it down to 4% should I be
blaming you for it getting up to 11 to
start with you people no doubt
were but but it' be right to I mean
there will be a mix of factors in all
the it's not that simple when you're
talking about the economy there's
obviously a mix of factors but all I can
do is control the things that I'm
responsible for and principally for a
government when it comes to inflation
that's about how much are we borrowing
and spending and if you borrow too much
as a government that adds to inflation
that's Rel L straightforward and
unfortunately right it's easy for
governments to do borrowing because
that's taking the easy way out then they
don't have to say no to anybody so I had
to spend a lot of last year making some
difficult
decisions that weren't easy but that's
what I want to deliver for the country
is what's long term and we first pledge
tick right you're one for one it's a
good start second one grow the economy I
would categorize you as being right on
the wire on this uh pay ending the news
you're going to get in two weeks which
will establish whether the fourth
quarter was positive or negative and if
it was negative that would be two
successive quarters in negative we would
officially be in recession that's going
to be a big figure for you 15th of
February isn't it yes that is and all
the indications are all the indications
are it may not be good news so if it's
not good news and we do actually are
officially tipping into recession would
you accept that that as fa so again you
when I got the job what were people
predicting they were predicting almost a
yearlong recession where the economy
would shrink by one and a half per. that
was what was forecast when I got this
job by the independent
forecasters that clearly hasn't happened
now you're right we're on the wire of
has it grown a little bit has it broadly
stayed flat but fundamentally what was
predicted was a year-long recession
where the economy shrank by quite a lot
that has not happened and we've
outperformed countries
and others can you say as we sit here
you have grown the economy yeah I'm I'm
conf since we last say yeah I am
confident that we will be able to keep
growing the econ will be I mean have you
actually grown it you think I think
relative to what was predicted we
definitely you're being a politician no
but that cont is you want to be a
straight talker a politician would say
well you know compared to what could
have happened but actually I think it's
both I think they're both if you want to
be judged specifically on the pledge
would it not be honest to say well we
haven't grown the economy but we're
hoping to we don't know is the answer
because as you said we'll find out in a
couple of weeks uh but I said and as I
said we'll see what it is right but
fundamentally also worth bearing in mind
the context and that's why people can
make their own judgment right we were
forecast to have a really bad time and a
big long recession and we're now talking
about we've certainly avoided that and
then how much has it grown or has it
stayed I'm not going to give you a yes
yeah I'm not going to give you a no yet
because it might surprise us in two
weeks but it's a big moment for you in
two weeks yes but again you don't want
to be the Prime Minister after saying
going to grow the economy to wake up and
discover that technically we went into
recession but again it doesn't stop
there does it no no it's about what else
is happening and if you think about You'
rather avoid that of course you'd always
rather avoid it but it's important to
look at other things as well real wages
are growing so people's wages are
growing faster than prices for 6 months
in a row our manufacturing sector last
year overtook France's in the size of
how big it is we have more big
technology companies grown in the UK
than France Germany and Sweden combined
and we're getting new investment in from
people like Nissan into Sunderland
allstead are building an offshore Wind
Farm off the east coast Microsoft are
doubling their footprint in the UK so
actually I think the momentum on the
economy is very positive and I said at
the start of this year we're pointing in
the right direction all to be fair
though I can't give you a yes yet well
that I think actually well we'll see
where we get there in a couple of weeks
but remember it doesn't just stop there
we can't just
I'm going to leave it as a possibly as a
possibly we're the bias to the positive
compared to where we were uh number
three reducing the national debt I think
we have to agree that that has not
happened yeah but we were always clear
about you agree no no no no no no no no
I was very clear when I did that press
conference we always measure these
things according to these independently
measured fiscal rules right we have
rules that we set out for what's
happening toor net debt was
97.7% of GDP in December 2023 it was
94.8 % in January 2023 that is not going
down that's going up it is absolutely
according to the rules that are
independently checked by the office for
Budget responsibility forecast to
decline within our rules I know but you
okay but you're talking about going
forward but that is how we measure debt
and I was very transparent about that at
the time your actual pledge said we will
make sure our national debt is falling
so we can secure the future of public
services and now are you saying you
didn't mean in the next year we were
crystal clear at the time I was crystal
clear no no no because this is not me
marking my own homework we have an
independent body our homework you did
jump ahead of yourself and said in
November you publicly said it was
falling and you had to be corrected and
you were warned be careful about
statistics if you're prime minister but
on this I'm very confident you accept
you were wrong to do that no because
what I'm referring to very clearly is
the rules that we have set out that are
independently checked someone else marks
our homework the office of budget
responsibility and they have been if I'm
I'm marking your homework but they've
been very clear that we're meeting I'm
marking your homework right now can't
give you a success no you can not for
this year not since I last saw you yeah
you can you could say looking ahead yeah
but that but that's always how we
measure debt that it's on a downward
trajectory that's how you build
certainty and security for public
finances that's the fiscal rules that
the chancellor set out before I even
gave that speech we'd set out the FIS we
disagree about this but no no you have
to that well I don't accept you you you
certainly haven't cut it in the first
year no but it's the rules that we set
out the rules that we set out have been
completely and utterly met okay every
time the chancellor has stood up the
independent body has said yes meting a
rules it's it's massively on track to
happen Okay NHS and it's got even better
NHS waiting list we have not made enough
progress you failed on that Pledge yes
because you said then just waiting this
will fall uh in fact they are slightly
coming down now but the waiting is still
nearly half a million more than it was
at the start of last year you accept
that that yes and we all know the
reasons for that and what I would say to
people is look we've invested record
amounts in the NHS more doctors more
nurses more scanners all these things
mean that the NHS is doing more today
than it ever has been but industrial
action has had an impact and in November
you talked about this in November we had
a month where there was no strikes for
the first time and do you know what
happened to the waiting list they fell
by almost 100,000 I mean impartial
observers have calculated probably half
of that waiting list can be ascribed to
the
strikes but you had one month where we
had words they would s of gone up up but
they wouldn't have gone up as fast yeah
it just we had a month in November no
strikes what happened waiting list fell
by 100,000 you said you said in your
January 2023 speech I know there are
challenges in A&E people understanda be
anxious when they see ambulances queuing
outside hospitals you should know we're
taking urgent action and going back to
your foreign secretary when he was prime
minister in 2011 I refused to go back to
the days when people have to wait for
hours on end to be seen an A&E and and
so we will ensure we get control back of
waiting times and yet a new statistic
that came out yesterday says nearly
35,000 patients a month waited for 12
hours or more for a hospital bed in 2023
that's a fact check analysis of NHS
England data it's 3,000 times higher
than in 2011 after 14 years of Tory rule
that's not a good thing no that's not
good enough and that's why we've been
working very hard to bring down the
people waiting for A&E treatment can can
I tell you a personal story at this
stage because I found quite shocking so
my mother is 79 and she had a heart
attack three months ago and she was
taken to a local hospital they said
you've had a heart attack we got to get
you to a cardiac unit down in Brighton
on Sussex coast and they blew that in an
ambulance at midnight fortunately my
sister was able to go with them and she
was seen when she got there and then she
was put on a trolley in a in a corridor
for nearly seven
hours the heart monitor battery ran out
nobody fixed it at one stage no nurse
came for three or 4 hours there were
between she reckons 35 and 40 other
people on trolleys in the corridors of
this a& most of them elderly without
people she said old men were begging for
bottles to urinate into others were
crying in pain or discomfort she said it
was a scene out of a war zone
and she couldn't believe what she was
seeing and she was also terrified of
course having been told you've had a
heart attack that no one was putting her
into the unit and actually trying to fix
her now once she got up there the
treatment she got was world class she
was fixed within 36 hours but I you know
I brought this one picture to show you
that's you know that's my mom who's
worked all her life right paid her taxes
all her life and when she really needed
the NHS yeah eventually the NS came
through but she could have died on that
trolley and I think that's
shocking yeah that is a shocking story
and I'm really glad that she's feeling
better now and send her my best and I'm
glad she got the treatment that she
needed this was a Monday night Prim
Minister this wasn't even the weekend
yeah it's not even a major city this is
Brighton and there were 40 yard people
on trolley in a corridor I mean I found
that just how can this be happening yeah
it's it's not good good enough the
performance in A&E and ambulance waiting
time has has has the Tory government
since 2010 has it failed on NHS do you
accept that no I don't because I think
we also are dealing with the backlog and
the legacy of covid which has just had
an impact and we can't escape that right
when you shut down the country and the
NHS for the best part of two years that
has had an impact on everything since
then and we just have to recognize that
reality now what we can do is put more
money in which we are hire more people
which we are put more diagnostic treat
in to get people the the tests and the
checks and the scans they need quicker
and ultimately the NHS is doing more
today than it's ever done in the past
and as we saw in November it made a
difference on the waiting list ambulance
times this winter A&E times this winter
are better than they were when I first
got this job so that shows that we're
making progress but fundamentally is it
good enough no um but we are making a
difference to people just this week for
example in a different way we've made it
easier for people to get medicines that
they need for things like sore throats
ear infections where now they can go and
see their pharmacist instead of having
to see their I think that's a great idea
I actually go to my pharmacist for
regular stuff and he's brilliant yeah
he's actually he's an Indian doctor in
Kensington he's fantastic and he just
says you need this boom he's normally I
grew up in a pharmacy my M was a
pharmacist and I think that's a very
good initiative but I do think you've
got to as a government sort this problem
out of AES the number of horror stories
I heard once we started telling people
about what happened to my mother was
really shocking
almost everyone that had to go into an
A&E had a similar Horror Story and I
don't blame the staff they completely
rushed off their feet and as I say once
you get up into the place you're
supposed to be the the treatment's
amazing we have an amazing Health
Service it's just getting up there is
hell yeah and we don't have enough
doctors or nurses that we train here at
home so one of the other things I
decided to do as prime minister was for
the first time in the NHS is 75 years
actually have a long-term Workforce plan
so now we've just started training
training more doctors more nurses more
dentists more of everything so that over
time we will be less reliant on people
needing to come here from abroad and
we'll have more doctors and nurses in
all our Hospitals now that will
obviously take time to make an impact
but it's an example of me doing what I
think is right in the long term no one's
ever done that before because generally
they don't think they'll be around to
see the benefits of it right I think
that be part of the problem yeah but
I've made the decision to do it one
thing you said to me last time we spoke
was you were going to sort or look at
you said the car parking for nhha staff
ISS isue it's now completely out of
control it's risen by 50% in a year the
price of parking a car at hospitals in
England nearly 50 million pounds is paid
by NHS staff to have the privilege to
park in hospitals where they're saving
lives I think this it's unconscionable
so after we spoke last time I went back
and looked into it and I'm actually able
to report that we have now rolled out
across all NHS trusts the free parking
policy which is focus on those who who
need it the most so people for example
blue badge holders are those with
disabilities uh people who have multiple
outpatient appointments because of their
condition parents who have got sick
children who need to stay overnight and
all NHS staff who are working night
shift why should any member of NHS St
pay well all of the people that why
should any of mentioned why should any
of them pay why should any of them pay
why should any NHS staff pay for the
privileg lots of people get lots of
people get to work in different ways
right so those are all the people that
we targeted free parking on I think most
people would agree those are the most at
need groups and when it comes to nurses
as you mentioned actually what we arrang
this year is for nurses to have a very
good pay rise so some a nurse that was
so they could spend it on parking well I
just making sure but remember everyone
comes think I think a no brainer if you
want to be popular with the Health
Service prime minister don't make them
pay for the privilege of parking well
what they want when they spoke to us
making sure that their staff are paid
well and and actually look you know a
typical nurse with 5 years experience
they got pay rise of around
,700 they got an extra bonus of around
£2,000 and just this year they're
receiving a tax around 50 you take
another look at it I I will always look
to see how we can support our staff
because I agree with you they do an
incredible job and we're very lucky to
have them so fail on NHS waiting list
fifth stop the boats uh you said we will
pass new laws to stop small boats making
sure if you come to this country
illegally you are detained and swiftly
removed now on the plus side you've
reduced a number of people last year
came over on the boats from 45,000 down
to 29,000 mainly due to the deal with
Albania big tick I mean that's a big
drop congratulations here's the bit I
don't get I've never understood this
Rwanda thing from the start of it during
it and where we are now it seems to me a
completely canding policy if I'm honest
I've made no bones about this I've been
saying it the whole time where even if
it succeeds even if miraculously you get
it through Parliament you end up just
with maybe 200 people at vast expense
being sent to Rwanda and if they have a
legitimate Asylum case we leave them
there none of this makes any sense to me
and I'm curious I mean Philip Johnson in
the telegraph said why Mr sunak decided
to pin his entire premise ship to the
removal of a few hundred at most
migrants to Rwanda will have historians
scratching their heads in perplexity and
I agree with it why is this the hill you
want to die on why is there not a way to
do this okay lots of there well one is
we've been through lots of other things
as well it's not the only thing I'm I'm
working on but it's a really important
one because it's a matter of fairness
first and foremost because I think
actually people coming here illegally
undermine the sense of fairness on which
our we can all agree on that right so
then you say what do we do about it well
Rwanda is one part of a plan as you said
we've already got the numbers down by a
third which has never happened before
right so that is progress we you would
have been sitting here and saying to me
look at that and I would have gone well
done yeah so on Rwanda why do you need
it because you need a deterrent cuz
simply if someone comes here illegally
they shouldn't be allowed to stay we
must be able to remove them and they
can't all go back to the country they
came from because it's very clearly not
safe or a war zone but you need to have
a safe alternative to send them and
that's why you need a policy like Rwanda
and I believe that when we get it up and
running when we get flights going off
and it's uncapped so we can send lots of
people there then people will stop
coming and you know why I know that
that's going to work is cuz as you
acknowledged it's worked with Albania if
I said to you I'll bet you ,000 to a
refugee charity you don't get anybody on
those planes before the election will
you take that back well I well I want to
get the people on the planes right of
course I want to get the people on the
planes right I want to get the people on
the planes I'm working incredibly hard
to get the people on do you think that
should be the priority when at the same
time the on just predicted we could hit
73 million people who in this country
right coming in not on boats but coming
in the normal immigration system by
2036 both people go well that seems
massively more problematic to me I
people talk to me a lot about illegal
migration as I'm sure they talk to about
you it's important that we grip it and
Rwanda is one part of an overall plan
that is working and and you say you
scratching your head Albania is an
example of why it's working we created a
new returns agreement with Albania it
meant that if people came here illegally
we could send them back and you know
what they stopped coming Randa and
Rwanda will do the
I do not think it's going to work for
you okay well we'll have to agree to
disagree that's my Grim prediction but
you don't have an alternative way to
solve that problem then uh no I'm not
prime minister right so and nor to the
labor party by the way nobody does right
and and if you don't believe in solving
the problem that's one thing I do I
think the British people do if you do
you need PL I'm going to give you I'm
going to give you a half pass okay and
on legal migration we've taken action
we're going to cut the numbers by about
300,000 more than anyone's has ever done
before that kicked in at the beginning
of this year and it will start making a
difference final
question you've lasted longer than
Alesis congratulations labor are 20
points ahead when are he going to call
the election when he going to go to the
people and test their confidence in you
look I spoke about that at the beginning
of this year so I haven't got more to
add on it but the choice at that
election is what matters and the choice
I think is becoming increasingly clear
because if you stick with the plan that
is working of course as we've been
through we have to make more progress
but the plan is working we are making
progress then we can have peace of mind
that the future will be better for our
children that everyone can have a
renewed sense of pride in our country
that is what I'm going for the
alternative is Labour party and K stama
who would just take us back to square
one because as you know he's had four
years he can't tell you what he would do
differently because he doesn't have a
plan and if you don't have a plan you
can't deliver any change nothing will
change for the better whereas I can do
that for people promise here's what I
say at the end is that uh K stama has
resolutely not delivered on his pledges
to do an interview with me for p Morgan
uncensored you've now done two in the
space of the last year I appreciate that
I think you do put yourself up to be
held to account more than he does if
he's watching this sakure you know where
to find me but I do you said you would
get me back a year later you have done I
appreciate your time and I wish you uh
well I wish you whatever success you
deserve this year prime minister well I
appreciate that and it's good to thats
to be seen doesn't it well I actually as
I said I think we are pointing in the
right direction at the beginning of this
year and we stick to the plan we'll make
progress on all these things that we've
been through incrementally as we get
through the year people will see that
things are getting better still going to
be here in a year's time I plan on being
so you'll come back for that third
interview we'll do the post election
interview back in this room in a year
right done deal good to see you you
too